wouldn't the right way to encourage  people to stop eating factory farm to  give them alternatives rather than  saying just stop so to answer your  question you said well isn't like sure  like advocating for veganism is is great  in all to stop factory farming but it  wouldn't actually just be more effective  to advocate for regenerative agriculture  or something it wouldn't it wouldn't  just be more effective it would also  mitigate the risk that  long-term veganism isn't healthy for  people we could potentially be pushing a  diet that's going to increase chronic  disease and at least i think we need  more studies to prove that it doesn't